[Música]
la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de Estados Unidos Nancy
pelosia anunció su renuncia como líder
del partido demócrata en ese órgano a
partir de la próxima legislatura el
presidente en la calificó como la
presidenta más importante en la historia
de la cámara baja analizamos en esta
visión
la fiscalía del Estado de Maryland en
Estados Unidos informó que al menos 158
curas cometieron abusos sexuales contra
más de 600 víctimas el reporte de las
autoridades Afirma incluso que la
arquidiócesis de Baltimore encubrió las
denuncias de los hechos que ocurrieron
desde 1940
la fiscalía de Colombia suspendió las
órdenes de captura de 17 integrantes de
la guerrilla del lln previo al inicio de
los diálogos con el gobierno de Gustavo
Petro los equipos negociadores Ya están
listos para las conversaciones que se
retomarán la próxima semana en Caracas
tenemos análisis
en France 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornadas soy
Valentina Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos en Estados
Unidos donde Nancy pelosi anunció que
renuncia liderazgo demócrata en la
cámara de representantes a partir de la
próxima legislatura el anuncio se
produjo Un día después de que los
republicanos obtuvieron las 218 sillas
que aseguran la mayoría y por tanto el
control de la cámara baja tras las
elecciones de medio término velocidad
dijo que permanecerá en el congreso
representando a San Francisco como lo ha
hecho durante 35 años el presidente Joe
biden en la calificó como la presidenta
más importante de ese órgano legislativo
previamente conversamos con Michelle
manat estratega demócrata que nos
explicó Quiénes son las figuras con más
peso entre los demócratas Para ocupar el
liderato en la cámara ahora que los
republicanos tienen el control
lo que también representa y es
importante del anuncio de Nancy pelosi
hoy es que vamos a ver un cambio
generacional en el nuevo congreso y yo
lo veo como muy positivo
hay un señor Joaquín jeffreys que hasta
el estado de Nueva York es africano
americano y es muy probable que él va a
resultar con la victoria para liderar
los demócratas en el nuevo congreso
va ayudando a él vamos a ver a una
señora Carmen del estado de
Massachusetts y Aguilar del estado
de California Así que vamos a seguir con
bastante representación diversa en el
congreso nuevo
y ellos van a tener el gran peso y el
gran el gran desafío de estar y mantener
una posición de y de oposición a los
republicanos liderados por Kevin
mccarthy
continuamos en Estados Unidos porque la
fiscalía general de Maryland identificó
a 600 Víctimas de abuso sexuales muchas
de ellas menores de edad por parte de al
menos 158 religiosos las autoridades
señalaron además que los crímenes fueron
encubiertos por las autoridades
eclesiásticas Cristóbal Vázquez
corresponsal de Franz 24 en Washington
nos contó que otros detalles se conocen
de estos casos
pues después de una investigación de
casi cuatro años el fiscal general de
Maryland Frost pide una moción a la
corte de circuito de Baltimore en esta
moción le pide el permiso para publicar
468 páginas de esta investigación donde
demuestra el fiscal general que cerca de
158 curas abusaron de más de 600 menores
de edad o personas durante casi 80 años
esta investigación Data de
1940 eran tan frecuentes los abusos dice
el fiscal que las víctimas terminaban
reportando estos casos a otros curas que
también estaban involucrados en esta
investigación y acusados de abuso sexual
además se dice que está en esta
investigación que la arquidiócesis de
Baltimore no solamente trató de encubrir
esto sino que a pesar de las
cuestionamientos a pesar de las quejas
de los jóvenes trataron de encubrir a
muchos curas durante muchos años
vamos a Colombia donde la fiscalía
suspendió las órdenes de captura y
extradición de 17 integrantes de la
guerrilla del lln esto Solo un día
después de que el presidente Gustavo
Petro confirmara que otti Patiño ex
combatiente de la extinta guerrilla del
m-19 a la que Petro también perteneció
será el líder del equipo negociador del
gobierno en las conversaciones que se
llevarán a cabo con esa organización
desde la próxima semana más temprano
hablamos con Camilo González pozo
presidente del instituto de estudios
para el desarrollo y la paz fin de paz
quien nos dijo que tanto apoyo tienen
estas negociaciones dentro del país con
el antecedente de los diálogos de paz de
la Habana que lograron la
desmovilización de las antiguas FARC hay
una expectativa
hay como un cierto escepticismo pero al
mismo tiempo mucha esperanza no el país
está cansado de guerras
hay una decisión de la inmensa mayoría
de los colombianos yo me atrevería a
decir que si el presidente tiene 65% de
favorabilidad más del 75% de la opinión
nacional
está de acuerdo con que se exploren y se
avance en este camino de negociación y
se llegue a lo que se ha llamado la paz
Total no solamente por acuerdo con el Ln
y otros grupos armados sino por el pasar
definitivamente el posconflicto cerrar
este capítulo de décadas de guerras en
nuestro país el presidente de Cuba
Miguel Díaz canel inició en Argelia una
gira internacional que También incluye
visitas a Turquía Rusia y china en su
primera jornada el mandatario argelino
del Madrid decidió Cancelar todos los
intereses pendientes de la deuda de Cuba
y aplazar su reembolso hasta nuevo aviso
el líder argelino también ofreció una
central eléctrica solar para paliar los
continuos apagones en la isla
vamos a Ucrania después de La retirada
rusa de gerson la ciudad y sus
alrededores vuelven poco a poco a la
normalidad tras ocho meses de ocupación
por parte de las fuerzas rusas han
salido a la luz varios cientos de
denuncias por lo que kiev considera
crímenes de guerra más detalles en el
informe
gerson tiene una sensación de libertad
desde La retirada de las tropas rusas
los ocho meses de ocupación dejaron a
una ciudad desangrada pero los
habitantes van encontrando poco a poco
su orientación y sus costumbres
como aquí en la plaza principal donde se
ha instalado un puesto de teléfonos
móviles para los residentes
las tarjetas sí me eran rusas e
intentado todo este tiempo no usarlas
estas tarjetas son ucranianas Esta es la
señal de nuestra Victoria estamos
liberados Gloria Ucrania y a sus héroes
los militares son vistos como Héroes a
pocos metros este soldado está
repartiendo autógrafos y haciéndose
fotos con los civiles pero por ahora no
se debería cantar Victoria incluso
siendo la retoma de gerson un tema de
Gran importancia para las fuerzas
defensoras
nuestra única opción es hacerlos
retroceder aún más por seguirlos hasta
el final
con la liberación de garzón y sus
alrededores ya se están denunciando
numerosos casos de tortura Durante los
meses de ocupación los prisioneros
fueron supuestamente atados golpeados o
electrocutados por los rusos
identificaron una docena de centros de
detención en los distritos de gerson los
ciudadanos fueron detenidos ilegalmente
allí los civiles fueron tomados como
Rehenes por los rusos la tortura se
llevó a cabo en cuatro lugares que
actualmente están siendo examinados por
los investigadores
en este sentido se han abierto más de
430 expedientes en esta región los
ucranianos afirman tener elementos que
podrían ser calificados como crímenes de
guerra se cumplen 50 años desde la
creación de la convención para la
protección del patrimonio mundial
cultural y natural en el acto de
conmemoración la UNESCO anunció un plan
de acción para las próximas décadas
basado en tres ejes un patrimonio
mundial más representativo más accesible
y más sostenible en francés 24
conversamos con Ernesto botón
subdirector general de cultura en la
UNESCO que nos habló de los principales
retos de la oficina de cara de los
próximos 50 años Bueno lo grande desafío
para los próximos 50 años el patrimonio
mundial tiene que ver con las
problemáticas que hoy en día están
afectando fuertemente todos los sitios
de patrimonio en todos los continentes
estamos hablando de la crisis climática
y de cómo eso pone en peligro muchos de
estos sitios debido al cambio climático
pero también a la destrucción de Bio por
conflicto armado o conflictos naturales
por otro lado está la temática en torno
al sobre turismo es decir como se
manejan los flujos de de de turista y de
personas y el tercero más importante es
Sobre todo como las comunidades que
viven dentro de los sitios del
patrimonio pueden también ser sujetos de
derechos y poder propietario de todo lo
que eso conlleva finalizamos con
imágenes del telescopio que reveló
detalles de dos galaxias
excepcionalmente brillantes que
existieron aproximadamente 450 y 350
millones de años después del Big Bang
los expertos señalaron que estas
imágenes dejan en evidencia que las
Galaxias del universo primitivo eran
mucho más brillantes de lo esperado
es todo por el momento en France 24
volvemos en breve
[Música]